I use my rife every single night for breast cancer for the past week when I wake up at night and
in the morning I am very dizzy. I rad in the rife handbook to make sure you drink lots of water
when you see the rife. If so does that mean at night or is it okay to drink enough adequate amounts
of water during the day also it is possible to program that the program on my rife needs to be changed.
I'm doing very well also could the disease come from supplements I'm taking.
So the dizziness is I do you know so you can you get dizzy because you are dehydrated so that's
the initial thought in this question as that the rife handbook is make sure you're drinking
plenty of water while every therapy you're told to drink plenty of water. They don't want you
to be dehydrated. But the reason is that is that cellular dehydration can bring about lots of other
issues and it can affect the effectiveness of different therapies. However dehydration
is not going to is typically not your first thing you think of when you think of dizziness
upon a rising and dizziness upon a waky. So you'd really want to ask a few more questions.
If you're if you feel when you stand up from a sitting position or you get up and stand up
or even sit up from a lying position and you feel a little bit woozy but then then you hold that
for 10 15 seconds and it passes and then you're fine. Really what that suggests is
adrenal insufficiency. So your adrenal gland kicks in a hormone that constricts your blood vessels
thereby increasing your blood pressure to shunt blood to your head so that you have adequate oxygen
supply upon rising from a sitting or lying position. That's how fast that hormonal progression works.
You're going to sit up from a sitting position sit up from a lying position. You literally get
at least 10 points elevation in your systolic blood pressure because of a sympathetic
told stimulation because of a hormonal release in order for you to
get adequate oxygenation to your brain. So if you don't get that if that doesn't happen that
is a side of adrenal insufficiency. So if that's the case if you'd say if the person says what I get
up at the middle of night I feel a little dizzy and then it subsides matter of a couple seconds to
20 seconds and then I find but I just got a kind of brace myself before I start walking.
That's a side of adrenal insufficiency. So you really need to think about taking some
adaptogens, some adrenal stimulation. We have plenty of adrenal type things
to take. It could be a side of low cortisol in the middle of the night.
If you don't get that does not happen during the daytime it's most likely you have enough
that you have enough blood sugar but also be a side of low blood sugar in the middle of the night.
So I don't think it has anything to do with hydration and I don't think it has anything to do with
the rifling. It has anything to do with any of your supplements taking. It's low blood sugar,
low adreadals and the dreadles need sugar and your brain needs sugar at the middle of the night.
So if you're already on a very low sugar diet because of your cancer and you're keeping your glucose
low levels and this is only happening at night then it's most likely cortisol or glucose or
combination thereof. So I would suggest you try adding some adaptogens or eating some protein
before you go to bed. So it's not about eating sugar but it's about having not being hypoglycemic
in the middle of the night. So eating some protein that's going to break down
slow. Well help maintain healthy. We'll do both things. We'll help maintain healthy
glycogen stores in a source of glucose and a source of stimulation of cortisol at night.